Uma área onde a computação quântica pode melhorar o aprendizado de máquina
está relacionada às funções kernel ou
matrizes kernel — vamos explorar o que são essas coisas
e por que precisamos delas. Para isso, vamos relembrar
três coisas: por que produtos internos aparecem no aprendizado de máquina,
por que problemas de aprendizado de máquina envolvem dimensões mais altas,
e o que são funções kernel.
Lembre-se de que o produto interno de
vetores reais n-dimensionais a
e b é dado pelo produto das magnitudes de a
e b e o cosseno de theta, o ângulo
entre eles. Isso é equivalente a multiplicar
cada componente de a pelo componente correspondente de
b e somar. Note que se os vetores são
quase ortogonais, como quando a
tem componentes zero onde b tem componentes grandes,
o produto interno é pequeno. Isso é equivalente a
theta se aproximando de pi sobre dois.
Da mesma forma, se a tem componentes negativos onde b
tem componentes positivos,
significando que os vetores apontam em
direções quase opostas,
e theta está próximo de pi,
o resultado do produto interno pode ser
negativo. Por fim, se a tem componentes grandes onde b
também tem componentes grandes do mesmo sinal,
então os vetores são quase paralelos e theta está próximo de zero;
o produto interno será grande
e positivo. Portanto, é muito razoável esperar que produtos internos
sejam uma medida útil de similaridade
entre pontos de dados. Nem todos os dados n-dimensionais
podem ser facilmente separados por um corte de n menos
uma dimensão, ou seja, uma linha,
plano ou hiperplano. Quando os dados não estão bem separados
em n dimensões, podemos incorporar os pontos de dados
em dimensões mais altas, digamos m dimensões, onde m
é maior que n. Isso é chamado de mapeamento de features,
frequentemente denotado como x indo para phi(x), onde
phi(x) é um mapeamento de números reais n-dimensionais para
números reais m-dimensionais.
É mais fácil visualizar isso quando
se dobra um conjunto de dados unidimensionais para
duas dimensões, ou quando se pega dados bidimensionais
e os incorpora em três dimensões.
Mas na prática, frequentemente incorporamos dados em espaços com milhares
ou até milhões de dimensões.
Um produto interno de vetores tridimensionais comparado a um produto
interno de vetores bidimensionais é uma diferença insignificante.
Mas um produto interno de vetores com um milhão de dimensões
se torna completamente intratável
para aplicar a um grande conjunto de dados.
Então as pessoas criaram um truque inteligente:
e se você usasse uma projeção
em dimensões mais altas com uma forma muito específica,
de tal forma que os produtos internos dos vetores em
dimensões mais altas sejam uma função simples dos
vetores de dimensão mais baixa? Ou seja, encontramos um mapeamento
dos nossos dados x para phi(x) de dimensão mais alta,
de tal forma que o produto interno no
espaço de features seja dado por uma
função simples nos dados de dimensão mais baixa.
Essa função k é chamada de função kernel.
O ideal seria que essa função kernel
fosse uma função do produto interno de
dimensão mais baixa em si. Isso nos daria o
melhor dos dois mundos: um espaço de features de dimensão muito alta,
mas com um produto interno barato e fácil de calcular.
À primeira vista, pode não
ser óbvio que isso seja sequer possível. Vamos ver
um exemplo simples em dimensões bem baixas.
Considere esse mapeamento de features específico: ele mapeia um
vetor tridimensional para um
espaço de nove dimensões. Acontece que
o produto interno do espaço de features mapeado de nove dimensões
é simplesmente dado pelo produto interno no espaço
3D original ao quadrado. Então o produto interno
do espaço mapeado usando as funções phi
exigiria o cálculo de cada uma das
nove coordenadas do
primeiro vetor e nove do
segundo, depois o próprio produto interno, que é
mais nove produtos e uma soma.
Isso dá um total de vinte e oito operações.
A função kernel requer três produtos
e duas somas, correspondendo a apenas quatro operações.
Isso foi para mapear um ponto de dados tridimensional para
um espaço de features de nove dimensões.
É fácil ver que isso poderia ser muito vantajoso
para espaços muito grandes.
A função kernel é tipicamente uma função contínua
que você pode aplicar a qualquer vetor no seu conjunto de dados.
Mas usamos funções kernel tomando
pares de pontos de dados do nosso conjunto
como argumentos. Aplicar uma função kernel a
cada par de pontos de dados no conjunto
resulta em uma matriz simétrica chamada matriz
kernel. O tipo de função kernel que você vai usar depende do
seu problema. Então, para recapitular:
descrever a similaridade de vetores nos nossos conjuntos de dados
frequentemente requer produtos internos. Produtos internos em
espaços de features de dimensão muito alta se tornam caros.
Então usamos mapeamentos de features correspondentes
a certas funções kernel especiais
que tornam o cálculo mais eficiente.
Mas essa restrição a funções kernel especiais
limita os tipos de mapeamentos para o espaço de features que podem
ser feitos de forma eficiente. Isso
pode nos impedir de separar bem os nossos dados.
Se ao menos houvesse outro jeito...
É aqui que a computação quântica entra.
O mapeamento de features de dimensão muito alta correspondente
a funções kernel pode ser realizado
em um computador quântico. No estimador kernel quântico,
a matriz kernel k é calculada
e, a partir daí, um algoritmo clássico de aprendizado de máquina pode ser
usado para realizar isso. Um ponto de dado x1
é carregado e mapeado, e depois
outro x2 é carregado
e mapeado. Como o produto interno de dois estados quânticos
está relacionado à probabilidade de medição,
podemos estimar o produto interno dos dois dados mapeados
fazendo medições suficientemente numerosas do
circuit resultante. Dessa forma, o circuit
pode nos dizer sobre um produto interno
em qualquer espaço de alta dimensão que o circuit consegue modelar,
sem que precisemos calcular classicamente um produto interno ou
função kernel. Há muitas formas de
personalizar e aprimorar esses métodos,
e de fato sempre há novos métodos sendo propostos
e testados. Esperamos que essa
visão geral tenha sido útil para contextualizar a
aplicação da computação quântica
aos métodos de aprendizado de máquina,
especialmente aqueles que envolvem kernels.